(crowd applauds)
- Our next guest is an
Oscar nominated actress
who might be best known for
taking all your money at the
poker table, and her role in
the Child's Play franchise.
The latest installment is
a series called Chucky.
You can see an all new episode
tonight on Syfy and USA,
but she was also part of this scary
and possibly very costly
scene in her bathroom.
(swooshing)
- No.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh no.
I made big mistake.
(crowd applauds)
- We're going to find
out what happened there.
Kinda looks like a dream bath.
Say hello to Jennifer Tilly, everybody.
(crowd applauds)
(lively music)
Have a seat.
Hello.
- Hi, How are you?
- I'm so good.
I said scary scene, but that
bath kinda looked magical.
- Well-
- Like what's the story,
did you forget it was on?
- Every single season, there's
only been two seasons so far,
myself and Don Mancini, the
creator of The Chucky series,
we like to take a naked bath
together for social media,
and, you know, and Don
is conveniently gay,
so he's not interested in me in that way.
- Conveniently gay.
- Yes.
- That's amazing, okay.
- So, this season I was like,
oh, I wanted to make sure
that I have a lot of bubbles
to cover my its and bits,
because I have more its
and bits than usual,
nobody wants to see them.
So I put a whole jug of
bubble bath in the bathtub,
and then I turned on the jacuzzi.
- And I went out of the
room just for a second,
and then I came back, and
obviously it did the trick,
But the good thing is,
there were lots of bubbles,
more than enough bubbles.
- [Kelly] It kind of looks amazing.
- Yes. And you know what?
Everybody's jealous because
Don and I do our little
naked bathtub scene and
they all wanna be in it.
But I think if you have other
people in the bathtub scene
it becomes salacious.
(kelly laughs)
And you have like,
the straight guys
- Not a conveniently gay man.
in the bathtub scene, it becomes like,
a weird sexual harassment thing,
like, Jennifer Tilly made
us take naked bath with her.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Human resources.
(audience laughs)
Yes.
- Favorite part of today
is conveniently gay.
So wait, have you ever
had a bathtub, like a bath
get away from you and
forget, like with your kids,
like you left it on and
then like water spillage?
- Uh, no.
- [Kelly] You've never done
that? No me neither, Michael.
- My kids just push the water out.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- They don't need it to go over.
- They just push it over, and just splash,
and try to dive and stuff, it's really-
- Like Aquaman, they're playing Aquaman,
all these things, yeah.
- Yeah, they think it's like
the ocean, and it's weird.
- Kids love bathtubs.
- Yeah, I do too.
- My boyfriend once...
Okay, I'm not gonna say he smokes pot,
because I'm not gonna say that,
but he gets very absent minded
- But he smokes pot. (laughs)
He turned on the bathtub
and he forgot about it,
and he wandered away, and he
went in his office doing like,
you know, the kinds of things
that seem very, very, very
important when you're in that
sort of floaty state of mind,
and then he heard a noise,
and he's like, "What is that noise?"
And it was like, glub, glub, glub.
and he looked, and
there was all this water
pouring under the door of his office.
And then he was like, "Oh no, oh no,"
he went in, there was
about a foot of water
all over the apartment.
And it turned out that a
lot of the other apartments
down below, they had major water damage,
and Phil paid for it all,
it was like, over $70,000.
He paid for it in his poker money,
which came out of his box
and comes in big bricks,
it's not like real money.
It's like, here, have a
couple bricks of money,
please don't sue us.
- I just wanna come over to your house.
- [Jennifer] Yes.
(audience laughs)
- You seem like so much fun.
- Yes.
- Like, and so does Phil. (laughs)
- So wait, so you're, I wanna
talk about your current show.
So it's Chucky and it-
- Chucky, Yes.
- Yes, Chucky.
So it's a series though
on, on Syfy and USA?
- Yes, it is.
- Okay, so what's going
on so far this season?
- Well, we're on season two,
because season one was
such a huge success.
We were 91% on the tomato meter.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Okay, nice.
- That means nobody had
anything bad to say about it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I play Tiffany.
It's really complicated, I
know my segment is almost over,
so I won't bore you with the details.
But Tiffany is in Jennifer Tilly-
- Please do.
(jennifer laughs)
I love you.
- Tiffany went into Jennifer Tilly's body,
so she's living the fabulous
life of Jennifer Tilly.
And so it's very, very, very
complicated, very bloody.
Tonight's episode is fun.
It's a parody of, you know,
those Agatha Christie movies
like Death on the Nile or
Murder on the Orient Express.
Tonight's called Death and Denial,
and all Jennifer Tilly's
friends are in it,
so Gina Gershon and Joey Pantoliano,
- Oh, like real friends?
- that were in Bound is in it.
- [Jennifer] It's a Bound
parody. My sister Meg Tilly,
I don't know how she got in, but you know.
(audience laughs)
Don was like, "Don't you have a sister?
I'm gonna put her in the show."
I was like, "Oh, all right."
(kelly laughs)
- And then my friend Sutton Stracke
from the real housewives is in it,
it's the first time she's
ever acted in her life.
- We did the scene once and
she goes, "That was really fun,
what are we gonna do now?"
And I said, "Well, so we
need to shoot the scene now
about 27 more times."
She's like, "What? We just did it."
- I said, "Well, it's on
the back of your head,
so we have to shoot it a bunch of times."
It's like, "Oh, okay."
But it's a really fun episode.
I'll give something away,
It's a murder mystery.
Okay, somebody dies and then I pretend
like it's a murder mystery
party, like, "Yay!"
(audience laughs)
"Who's the murderer?"
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- We don't know who the
murderer is. (audience applauds)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Could be me.
- I love you so much, like
deep down, you are awesome-